I don't care they started it it is
you're all insane they started it I
completely forgot about this video
actually um but Joan Rivers who has
since passed uh in
2014 she was asked about uh what's going
on with with Hamas and Israel as the
last time that not the last time they've
done it many times over the years
including the day after we left Israel
just a few months ago when they were
lobbing Rockets over and you know
building tunnels to to murder people and
everything thing 2014 she's at an
airport and TMZ asked her what she
thought and I this video I actually was
the one I think that sort of made it go
viral I found it and got it out there uh
this is from years ago but today somehow
people started finding it again and I
and just listen to to John Rivers so I'm
trying to get celebrity reactions to
what's going on with the Palestinians
and Israelis right now let me just tell
you if New Jersey were firing Rockets
into New York we would wipe them out I
am so bored we heard they were digging
tunnels from New Jersey to New York we
would get rid of Jersey so I don't want
to hear anymore oh we'll do a partial
truce the Palestinians you cannot throw
rockets and expect people not to defend
themselves what about the civilian
casualty rat civilian then don't put
your goddamn things in private
homes I'm sorry don't don't you dare put
weapon sashes in in in private homes and
then we say get
of of course we're going to do it the
response normally is where are where are
the civilians supposed to go I don't
care they started it it is you're all
insane they started it what are you all
saying they started the Israelis did not
throw their for for months this has been
going on how do you what are you
supposed to do how do you resolve I know
cuz I have been over there that's how I
know and I wish the world would know and
BBC should be a shame
and CNN should be a of themselves and
everybody stop it already you know like
Dwight Howard tweeted Palestine took it
back Selena Gomez tweeted uh a pro Gaza
Selena Gomez oh yeah that college
grad all right thank you than you so
much well Selena said
that Rihanna had to take back tell her
let's see if she can spell
Palestinian I'll ask her right now we
love you have a great day man only only
Joan Rivers could make you laugh in the
midst of all that um all right obviously
we're going to have to do more of this
and this is not the way I like to do a
show and I I'm most proud of the shows
that we do when when we're laughing at
the end and I thought man that was a
funny show that that's why people tune
in um but I guess my job now is a little
bit different uh because clearly this
this thing is also going to just reach
into every sort of sector of society
like the world is like we either stand
for truth and and honesty and reality
and Western values or not
and this is this just ain't going
anywhere for
now